[موسيقى]
عبر بطاقه تعريفيه صغيره تبحث هديل عن
منزل ام ريماس والهدف فحصوا صيانه جوالها
لتامن حفظ خصوصيتها في وقت كثرت فيه حالات
الابتزاز وفي ركن منزلها تعمل اشفاق
القاسمي على صيانه العشرات من جوالات
النساء خصوصا وقد صارت متمكنه في هذه
المهنه بعد دورات مكثفه خضعت لها ضمن
برامج التمكين الاقتصادي الممولي من مركز
الملك سلمان للنازحين في مارب يعني من اول
كان مقتصر على الرجال
بعدين لما نجحنا وشفت حاجه همم السوق لهذا
العمل يعني احتياج النساء والحفظ
وخصوصياتهم اخذ دوره للصيانه الجوال
وطورت نفسي يعني دخل في العمل بهذا المجال
بديت يعني الاهل والاصدقاء والجيران
بتوسعت طبعت كروت وانا نشرتم يعني
والمدارس كينج جوالي خربان سمعته لنا في
مهندسه جوالات شلت الكرت قلت ادور عليها
صبرت لي جوالي الحمد لله عشان نجيبه عندي
عشان الخصوصيات تحافظ لنا على خصوصيتنا
الحرب حولت بمشروعها الصغير ظروف الاحتياج
الى كسب وانتاج لاعاله اسرتها وتبحث عن
تطوير مهنتها بفتح اول محل لصيانه الجوال
في معرفه
يعني اشتغل يعني العمل في المنزل يعني
يجوز الصعوبه بالعنوان الى المنزل
ثانيا كده صعوبه كبيره فتح محل اللي يكون
المحل يعني يحتاج يعني
الايجارات مرتفعات يطلبون لعده شهر مقدم
او لسنه مقدم وكذلك الديكور والاكسسوارات
والاجهزه والا امتلك المبلغ الكبير هذا
النازحات التي تدربنا على مهن مختلفه في
اطار مشاريع التمكين وتحسين سبل العيش
المموله من مركز الملك سلمان شقه اشفاق
طريقها نحو الاكتفاء الذاتي وصارت تكسب
عيشها واسرتها من مهنه هي من الكويتها
محمود الحميدي العربيه مارب